[Music]
hey welcome to hear made this dusty
brown is easy i am your host Steve
Rannazzisi thank you for joining me
again episode two of the podcast I want
to take a sec to thank all of you who
took time to rate and review the podcast
on the various places you listen to it i
truly appreciated it really helps
building traction getting up some of the
charts and you know get more eyes on it
so that was really cool my artwork is
not final yet I know it looks a little
like just kind of put together we're
still working on something kind of cool
so I'm doing that too yeah the I know
people were not typed that it was truly
like an original you know episode
because you know bird had to put it up
on his and and he had kindly given me
the audio and but I wanted everyone to
hear sort of how this whole thing came
about and you know why I've taken some
time to kind of figure it out and do it
correctly so all things comedies been
really wonderful so I want to thank them
and yeah we're going to have original
gas going i'll forward from here on out
and my first one is mark Duplass and he
most of you know mark if you know
because of the league you listening to
this podcast because of me and yeah he
played peed on the league for the seven
seasons we did the show together but
mark is it's a filmmaker and he's a
producer who's a writer as a director
and his brother and Jay and him have
made movies for over 20 years now
they've they've been to all the
festivals and they just are true
creative artists who have original ideas
and our great storytellers and Mark is
one of the smartest dudes I know and
when I asked him do the podcast he was
like absolutely and he's a tremendous
reader he every time on set I would ever
see him
you know he was never really idled he
would always be either reading something
on his phone script or whatever or
reading a book and so I knew that he
would have you know a great idea for a
book and he gave me some ideas and we
kind of talked about him and you'll hear
in the podcast of which book he should
do and then he's like I want to do the
notebook and it sounds so silly but
that's really it's kind of a fun you
know ways into the most people know the
story of the notebook but this is sort
of a fun way into the mind set of
someone who would just sit down and read
the notebook marks a genius I love him
and his family and so yeah this is um
this is different than the first one
obviously we're going to not drunk or
stoned or anything we did it in the
daytime in marks office so and we're dad
so you know day drunk is not always a
possibility I mean I'm not ruling it out
but I'm just saying it's not always
going to be we're not gonna be able to
do it all the time so we're poor stones
over talking about the notebook just two
men in there almost 40 s and you know
being sensitive with one another it's a
real fun episode we don't really you're
not going to learn anything about the
actual you know story from beginning to
end we kind of go off on some great
tangents but that's what this thing's
going to be about so sit back relax and
enjoy mark Duplass and the notebook
[Music]
yeah nope you find my dressing yeah you
could just do it let it cool um but yeah
no uh yeah we've I've done 14 okay and
none of them some of the books have been
hysterical just we talk to the guests
just tells me funny stories about their
life and then some of them have been
like dark dark place example you're all
yes so it never been a thing where it's
like you're not amid all the tone let it
be yeah but I'm interested mostly and
because the list of the books that you
gave me I saw you reading Infinite Jest
I was on set like season six or
something quietly sitting there by
yourself reading that book and to me it
looked like a daunting task I don't know
how in between takes you could read a
book look it's a big it's a big book
there are a lot of footnotes in it i
think what i was doing is while the
league was hitting its intellectual low
point you and I would say is late season
six I was trying to find something
really hoity-toity to counterbalance
that might ya feel really smart mm-hmm
and also I was trying to get honestly
get the goddamn phone out of my hands
because mm-hmm I think somewhere in the
editorial dungeon of the league there's
a lot of footage of us before the takes
and I want to see how long we were on
our phones before Jeff yelled action and
I think it's less than a second I would
argue to say that after healed action if
there were many takes we're here yeah
let the slant away and then in the
pocket then you're in the scene mm-hmm
do you think that affected us i'm sure i
think it did especially the way we
worked that we were sort of in the
moment at all times and then to take
ourselves out of it but yeah yeah i know
but you
out there and you read it to me I did I
went for infinite jest and I made
scripts that's like sort of work on the
side I can see doing that but like to
sit there and read Infinite Jest that
you must have it was that's a lot I
really needed something yeah and I was
really I was really going for it um but
yeah I think also like this some [__]
that happens to you as a dad where you
stop reading completely because well you
never read so does yeah I matter yeah
but like you like I stopped reading
completely for the five or six years
that was required to keep my children
from falling down the stairs and dying
and then I was also around the time
where I was like oh god my youngest is
now four and I can pick up a book again
and this is this is just the most
exciting thing in the world yes for an
hour at least an hour day you don't have
to worry about like making sure they're
safe or anything that you can sit there
and have that time I'll fall down but
they won't die growing up did you were
you a tremendous reader throughout your
I was like that that kid who was like
nose buried in the book kind of thing
but I did have a really great experience
reading because my dad didn't do a very
good job cleaning out or curating the
library in our house and so there were a
lot of really grown up books really low
on the shelves when I know better now to
like put those oh I'm gonna go ahead and
just like I'm gonna put the Charles
Manson by over like above four feet yeah
just in case you know yeah but I got
helter skelter when I was like seven
years old I don't even know what that is
that it's the story of Charles Manson
and and all the people he murdered but
more importantly what you remember as a
seven-year-old when you're reading
helter skelter is that what they would
often do is they would sneak into
people's houses and hide underneath
their bed oh my god and worse than worse
than I getting up and murdering them in
the middle of the night they would just
stay there all night Oh kind of observed
read that it's said that and I was like
how did you sleep well I didn't I didn't
and I've made j sleep with me for in the
same bed until I was about 11 years old
would you did you hand him the book and
be like did you ever eat like this is
what's going in there we shared
everything yeah she's menger people dead
and.and I did I are actually now thing
but yeah I made Jace Lee with me until I
was like 11 until he was I think 15
because i read that i read even jaws is
a terrifying read yeah with all the
Sharks tough deliverance was a wonderful
read for me at about eight years old my
mom read it I remember her reading it
and I remember picking it up on a
vacation and reading like a chapter and
being like this is just this is scary
and like this is this is fun for you it
still works as a scary but is it really
i mean i've seen the hunger presents but
yeah it's it's it's goddamn terrifying
creepy clowns are always no cell range
but they always work so yes I was like
not like a voracious reader like oh
books in my only world and I don't
communicate with the outside world but I
was into it and then I think like once I
got to high school and stuff it was
there was that era of just like and
everything is required reading and I'm
not too psyched about this I never need
you to worry I you could you read the
required reading another thing I mesh
yeah I got them all and then and then I
think once I got to like college and
post college that we've got into more of
that elective reading thing that's like
oh yeah this is gonna like enrich my
life yeah and you needed Infinite Jest
towards the end of the league and I
understand why so really I really did a
little more class in your life and and
by the way like it took me four times
she read infinite jest like it everybody
has a couple of infinite Jeff's failures
and it's okay nobody likes we'll talk
about it but you read 100 pages and you
realize oh there's no way I'm going to
make it what they are so difficult is it
word so it's a little leaven hunger page
book but about 250 to 300 of those pages
are footnotes in particular there's one
footnote that goes on for over a hundred
pages why so you need to bookmarks when
you're reading Infinite Jest you have
the page that you're on and then you
have the section of the bookmarks for
the mage in the back of it and once you
hit that first footnote it's the
equivalent of like hitting Heartbreak
Hill in a marathon but at like at like
mile three and while you're not
specifically tired you know there's
24-month bbming and they know where I'm
going to make it and so it demoralizes
you and it puts you out of it so I had
three failed
temps at infinite jest but all the
people that I just know and respect like
when you get through this thing it will
it will be worth it you just gotta dig
in and stick in did you feel that way
when you think I did its but it's
probably my overall favorite book and
there's a there's just a way that they
look at recovery in that book that is
it's just incredible haven't seen
anything like it before so it's it's
it's worth it but I would say if you
want to read Infinite Jest offer
yourself at least two to three fails and
don't feel bad about have you ever
failed reading another book have you
ever started both in like I'm oh yeah I
miss a friend of mine read Moby Dick
over the course of two and a half years
on the toilet he's just likes it was
like I'm going to read eight to ten
pages every day and I'm going to get
through it and I thought that was the
most brilliant idea and I still couldn't
do it and i think was reaching what and
you did it just trying it on the toilet
yeah it was just too much water just
water everywhere though there's a whale
I add the moby dick thing was was too
much for me I tried Oh Ulysses is the
James Joyce book that's like the most
difficult complex book of all time and I
just them peoples talk funny really yeah
like old timey stuff and they talk weird
I just I don't yeah you're like I'm not
this is not some out yeah and I find
like if you're interested in the theme
or there's some sort of there's
something in it that that holds you but
if you're not the language if there's a
language barrier in the way they talk
and you got to go like my thing is I
don't want to go back and read five
pages back because I don't remember the
reference to what they're talking about
one hundred percent I mean there's also
like those those books by Elena Ferrante
the Neapolitan novels is like four of
them my brilliant friend and and those
are supposed to be like pretty easily
easily accessible but I look at them and
you the first page is a family tree that
goes back five generations and i got our
memorized who is whose aunt and uncle
and I'm just like yeah you don't want to
do like you you gotta realize that
Netflix is out there and you're
competing without a thing and you gotta
do something you got to make it easier
on me and they get it done in two hours
yeah latex modulus lamo climb inside of
two hours
what if you go on a vacation do you have
like all right this is a vacation style
book that I'm going to read this kind of
heat on vacation I mean Katie and I
every now and then we'll go on like a
grown-up vacation in which case I'll
just bring whatever book I want it's
fine but if it's like a family vacation
and I know I'm going to get limited
reading time and it's going to be
heavily interrupted with dad playtime
stuff I have a series of books that I
call the elevated beach reads hmm which
are like the equivalent of like a really
good popcorn movie like not just not
just like a regular power move but it's
got something to offer yeah and there
are a lot of books like that there was a
book called the Goldfinch that came out
a couple years ago thats it's really
great it is a beach read it's
page-turning it's fun but it's got
history and it's interesting there's a
book called beautiful ruins that does
that same thing so I try to like I try
to identify the book that's like another
cultural equivalent of watching like a
rival or something like that worth yeah
would be interested in video but your
movie but like hey there's some sod it's
not so bad yeah those are good beach
books to read I have ever gone back and
like I know you said you read it in
Finch sdn believe but have you ever gone
back and like I need this I need to
reread this because this makes me feel a
certain way yeah they announce mean a
certain gets me out of a certain mood or
whatever a hundred percent I'm I am
English as a nostalgic a person as it
comes and so like yeah I have playlists
on my phone of songs that I need to
revisit so I can feel a certain way and
usually those are successful with music
but books I find I'm rarely successful
going back re reading and getting the
juice out of them that I got out of them
when i first read them like when i read
the world according to GARP when I was
15 like my first John Irving book I was
just like this is the epitome of
intellectual writing and storytelling
and how he does this is amazing and I
went back to reread it like like three
or four years ago and it's just
interesting i'm a writer now and I kind
of understand structure and I just see
holds all the mac i see all of us really
all the machinations and it's
manipulative and he pulls and it's still
good because I'm attached to who I was
when I first read
it but it's definitely not the thing you
know so a lot of times when I'm talking
about books with people or even movies
too though they'll be like what's your
favorite book of all time and I'm like I
have to have two categories I need I
need empirical book and then I need
reading experience what makes me happy
while reading it yeah or also what moved
me the most for who I was at the time
you know and no like for me like peak
that you will never top where the red
fern grows when I was ten years old like
what that did to me when he took those
dogs away from me spoilers I did I read
that when i was at you yeah yeah yeahs
you I don't remember it but yes I do
remember Sofia where the red fern grows
yeah mo farm I got some required stuff
done right symbolism but nothing beyond
that yeah so yeah oh yeah oh where the
Red Fern Grows eating experience you
know like movies when I saw Titanic in
the movie theater I'll never I'll never
a boat like that I thought three times
in the movie rights so [__] hard and
I'm I'm ashamed of it i mean you watch
the movie now it's the movies not great
I you know I lost it here's how i watch
it now when it's on like T&T that's like
six hours on TV and I never can get
through the whole thing and they break
it up I bet you if you sat down and you
watched it straight through no
commercials you definitely find some
idle results yeah you would find serious
holes and I think that it would not do
nearly what it did for you at the time
so yeah for me like there have been
books there have been times i have read
things I remember when I was 27 so I
guess yeah we hadn't started the lead
yet I had just made the puffy chair I
just shot it and I had a feeling it was
going to like do something for my career
but I was still playing in bands at the
time and I was like am I going to be a
musician am I going to be a filmmaker
what am I going to be and had a long bus
ride back from maine to New York City
and I was staying with Katie's sister
and I need to grab a book before I leave
and like the only thing they had that
wasn't like just something really
political that I was not interested in
was Bridges of Madison County its ugly
head everybody reads this blog ever I
loves it and drive this book you know
and I sat on that bus and I [__] cry
my eyes out really the whole way back
home it's a big the big message and the
book is this type of certainty comes but
once in a lifetime and it's about fate
and it's about destiny and which road
are you choosing and I because of that
book i was like i am giving up my life
as a musician because i want to be a
filmmaker and say closer to katie who
I'm eventually going to marry which was
true and my brother who I was close with
and like I kind of owe my entire film
career to the bridges of madison county
on the greyhound bus headed down i-95
yet really i mean that if that's what
you took away from it and look I gotta
make a decision I have to kind of [__]
or get off the pot yeah wait am I going
to go and and they make it work for me
that's amazing yeah Bridges of Madison
County Bridges of Madison County baby
and you cried I mean but that's you know
I only saw the movie you know I'm always
had a little bit of issues that we did
emotional yes which is why I when you
told me this is the book that you want
to do with the notebook I I it makes a
little sense to me because I know you
and we are emotional people but I just I
for all the books you've read and you
know all the stuff that you've written I
just I'm like wow this is something that
I wasn't expecting you to choose I it
was a gut reaction I didn't check it and
I'm really gonna regret it later um but
if I'm being totally honest I think it's
it's the most like deeply linked to who
I am in my core and then I talked a
little bit about being a nostalgic
person before but that crying thing that
you and I have talked about three years
or shared its it i think it's hooked
into just a deep romanticism you know
and i know i can speak for me i won't
speak for you but like I found out early
on that like if I was funny and a little
sarcastic I would win right like they
like my art if I did that yeah and like
you get up on stage and you make people
laugh and like you get a little like
funny and sarcastic and even cynical
sometimes and like the audience's did
you
I think you're smart and everything so I
just went that way because that's what
made me win but like me is an eight or
nine-year-old kid I'm at home crying in
front of same time next year star man
somewhere in time you have all the great
romantic movies and and books and I
picked up the notebook as a joke when I
was on tour one time was like oh this
will just be funny you know and it just
it just ripped me in half and I don't
know what it is my senses come down
everything and I'm like this is more me
than anything else i'm doing well i can
honestly say I mean I've never read the
book but I saw the movie and I don't
know if you read it before you saw the
read the book first then solve it saw
the movie I don't get movie I cried
throughout the entire movie yeah the
ending is is buckling to me and so I
can't imagine and I would assume that
the book is probably better than the
movie it's pretty great the book is able
to attenuate the mystery of whether this
is actually her husband Noah she really
should be with or the James Marsden dude
who's me I can't remember and there i
know i remember in the book and the
movie you're watching it and you're like
well Gosling was on the cover so I'm
pretty sure that's who got it in the
book you're like which way did she go
like halfway through the book you don't
know really whether she's going to end
up with Noah or the other guy and maybe
it's because it was my first Nicholas
Sparks book maybe if you've read another
one you're like oh I know where this is
hidden but the mystery of that so I was
emotionally engaged in a level of like
watching the Super Bowl and pulling for
my team I was like if Noah doesn't get a
girl so you were team Noah I was team
Noah all the way man I think there were
people that were team James Marston sky
not for them well I don't read that book
I mean I you assume like probably a
romantic person would read that ok
obviously want the Gosselin guy or no
way to get the girl but I mean I wonder
if there are people that are like why
didn't you just choose a logical choice
and a safe play and there's nothing
wrong with that by the way I this shows
you my perspective I never considered
that that was even a possibility because
of the romantic nature of who I am but
you're probably right I'm sure there are
some people particularly some like
post-world war two people who are just
like a with good guys and the other suit
probably smells great put some food on
your table my father-in-law would have
been like she just just been thus a
choice and that's it all this other
nonsense she has to put herself through
their people that may have like see Matt
but not but when gosselin gets rained on
and that white shirt and you see through
everything he got ripped for that movie
ooh by the way yeah well he I think he
knew that that was like this is like a
week Kevin Connolly wasn't the other guy
right wing he was like just some guy and
he became Ryan Gosling in that in that
movie yeah that's what made him Ryan
Gosling rank so he was in like murder by
numbers with uh with Sandra Bullock
before them but I don't think he had
been no that was like that that was
natural charisma yet when the other guy
Andy Marsden but there it Kevin Connolly
is in there some yeah he's like his best
friend like they were like war buddies I
thought her so I think he's wearing like
a really bad news paper boy hat if I
remember correctly Conley I think so in
the book how do they handle do they ever
do they ever tip the cap that what is
going to happen towards the end of the
book as the story goes along so I can
remember the movie do they ever have
flashbacks early on that you know what
where it's heading to the book does a
much better job keeping the mystery of
where you think you're going and who
might the the man be that she ultimately
ends up with so that the book does that
a little bit better but the truth is
none of that [__] [__] matters
because you're in the middle of this
love triangle and that the core of this
book is this really corny really cheesy
but very primal thing of am i following
my heart or my following my head and I
think that's why that movie was
something that you and I could connect
you or that book and then what like you
know the in 89 year old woman who reads
this like gets into it you know and it's
weird because I just made this movie
blue jay with me and sarah chalten by
the way thanks man beautiful and and I
was like yeah I'm gonna make this like
black and white kind of like raw indie
movie and it's going to have all this
like integrity and I was doing all my
like highfill
indie filmmaker talk and then like while
I was shooting the movie I like lay down
hit the pillow and I was like oh I think
I'm just making the notebook in black
like I think is that what you were
holding your size except if you're
thinking about that you like at home man
is this the notebook am I honest can I
get there and then I went back to set
the next day and I was like okay guys I
realized something last night and to my
earlier point of like is a beach freedom
as an elevated be treated us like
there's a lot of notebook going on here
let's just let's just try to be elevated
notebook let's just do yeah let's do our
about a great angle and but then at the
end of the day I was just like it was I
mean legitimately I came off of that
movie and I was like this is the most me
I felt as an artist and probably like 10
years oh and i love i love Cyrus and I
love those movies that I made that have
that kind of dark cringe-worthy humor
and I'm so interested in that and I took
Jay and I've got good at expressing that
and I love them but in terms of like a
pure like just vomiting of myself into a
piece of art it's all it's all blue jay
and it's all God to the notebook yeah i
mean what got us in the door the sarcasm
the charm and that it's still there but
we didn't kind of become more
comfortable with who we are i'm going to
die you know i'm 40 dude I've seen
mannheimer own men on planes reading a
book right and then what you could just
see it I could look over and then
they'll just look close it for a second
and they'll just have that moment where
you could tell like they're they're good
at cry or that something's happening in
that book then it's making them well up
with emotion may and they're not going
to do it from seat 19 be there all the
way they're gonna wait there in a suit
and they're on the way to Denver for a
conference and this is nothing who they
are this is not when deep down inside it
might be who they can be if they just
let themselves go a little bit that's
kind of where I'm headed right now I'll
have you all know right now that we're
sitting on the third floor of my office
and we thought Clark but just to Steve
Rannazzisi s4 o'clock is an area that
I'm calling my regression chamber which
has a newly refurbished nintendo system
oh that is like spot a VCR
and a lot of like use VHS tapes off of
ebay where'd you find a VCR uh you can't
off ebay they're like you can't go like
best buy no no no that'll make me more
and i bought like a hundred a stack of
like a hundred VHS tape so there are two
copies of soul man in here one of them
really yeah and but it was in it was
tied to the notebook my belief that yes
it's fun to go back and watch one of
your old favorite movies like valley
girl or something like that on itunes
and now it's wide screen and digital and
perfect but when you put in the VHS that
like has some fuzz on it and the wheels
travel slowly and the sound warps a
little bit and you watch it on a old Ted
telugu which I found off of craigslist
by the way probably a 32 inch it is it's
a 32 tube with a curry on any craigslist
by the way everybody's just giving them
away cuz nobody wants them they're huge
and they want to watch we if you watch
like the notebook on that TV it's such a
difference from watching it like on your
laptop or something yeah so this is your
regression corner it is my aim bird
regression chambers and I and I come
here and I like did you curate those VHS
tape so it was just a box of eat like I
get four separate lots from being honest
and and and yes it's some really fun
stuff like I got some old terminators in
there and everything but but a lot of it
is is towards my bent of i mean i have i
have the notebook in there it's in there
i'm going to be honest um i have ever
read a book that you're like I got to
make this into or this has not been made
into the proper movie I have to make
this into the proper movie or end or
like no one's seen this yet this is I
need to talk to whoever wrote this book
yeah we have had those thoughts for sure
the first one that like hit me really
hard honestly was Infinite Jest like oh
my god if there's a way to make a movie
out of this has anyone everything right
incredible I no one has tried on I think
Mike sure has the right to created the
office but it's practically impossible
to make a movie out of it it's so long
and you could make a miniseries out of
just footnotes if you're interested and
then I'm trying to get the other ones
that we really if we really chase things
through the year i had this we
your thing where when something is
really really good and meaningful to me
as a viewer I kind of don't want to go
near it as a filmmaker because I'm none
of you feel this at all but I feel like
the older I get as an artist and maker
of [__] like the more precious my
viewing experience has come to me when
they're really work because either i see
through the lines on things and how
they're made or you just become more not
cynical but just harder to be wowed like
you are when you were seven yeah and
when something hits me now like moonlit
hit me the moonlight hit me this year
you know like the way that hit me I'm
just it just knocked me out it was a
great experience and so I feel that way
with stand up yeah I knew I want to
touch it I just want to be a fan I get
to do that because most stand-ups I you
know when you watch Chris Rock I'm not
gonna go over to them and give them a
tag after I don't have to get involved
it I can just watch it as a fan yeah but
you do as you get older you there's
nothing that's ever going to hit me like
Chappelle first special or like even
when I see Chappelle now at his new
stuff it doesn't have the same sort of
feeling that it did when I was you know
20 years old you gave me bill burr yeah
I didn't know bill until I was in my
late 30s and you gave me one of those
Netflix special you sent me with it and
I remember it I was like all right I'll
check it out to Steve's buddy and I was
just like your body is honest like this
no no I mean maybe to a fault but like I
got a lot of ways I'm special just came
out on Thursday 31st really yeah as news
he did it at the Ryman and Nashville's
check it out i think it's called walk
your way out of here or something like
that i love that guy yeah but yeah i
understand me saying it's uh I guess you
just go okay that's a beautiful piece of
art and that I just can enjoy it I don't
have to get into it that's what I'm
looking for and I'm having a harder time
these days finding that as a film viewer
I like feel like I've seen like kind of
all the great movies that are out there
and then I'm looking for new great ones
each year and same thing with TV series
there's a lot out there and I surf
around but I don't really get moved by
it and where I'm actually headed lately
is books and that's where I'm getting it
from because i'm relatively uneducated
on what the great books are you know
you show up to movies you look at the
AFI top hundred movies of all time I've
seen all of them yep you look at the top
100 books of all time you probably ready
Matt no I haven't ya really read like
you know fifty percent of them so I'm
still like a little bit of a kid in the
book realm so I can get a lot of those
great you know yeah periences left still
you know and like I would spin like
reading sci-fi books lately which I was
never into and was always judgmental I
know and like they have all these
incredible books and I so I'll go to
guys I'm like what's your favorite book
and I get to read the relative Godfather
or jaws or rocky of the sci-fi world
because I'm new to it when your brother
passing back and forth or who do you go
through for references for bogo yeah I
got to read they usually go to like
people who are like you know majorly in
the middle of it like Neil Gaiman is
like V like sci-fi and graphic novel
writer I just go straight at him and
then I have music friends like my friend
Maggie is my music supervisor and I'm
just like I'm [__] old I don't know
what's going on will you like send me 10
cool band that's what I do at The Comedy
Store I need it my buddy Nick Yousef
just knows every band that comes out and
which ones like you know when the
Coachella poster comes out God's one of
the ones at the bottom yes it once you
know like I don't know it the first
seven or eight the man a tab and this is
like the eye chart when you go he's
already smaller but I was like all the
ones at the bottle so we'll just
constantly send me something really
valuable they are they could be like i
would pay 20 bucks for a curated
playlists from them from those p exactly
yeah but thank God we're friends with
him yeah you didn't you adapt a book
into something or did you try a couple
of things like there was a time where I
thought I was going to be like I want to
be a big Hollywood screenwriter you know
um and so I've done like three or four
different books through the years for
studios you know and did they give you
those books or they like here can you do
this or is it like somebody usually it
was like a job that they were going out
we offer a writer and I would pitch on
it and try to get the job you know and
that's what's really really fun I've
done a lot of that but I mean as you
know just like only one out of 30 things
that gets hired or developed gets
actually made into a movie so a certain
point you do get a little frustrated
were just like well I made good money it
was great and but like we all just
talked about making
movie for a year and then like nothing
happened yeah yeah so I kind of ended up
moving out of that game and and and
quite frankly realize that all all like
false modesty aside like what I am good
at is actually not taking a book and
making it into something that will make
a hundred million dollars at the box
office for better for worse my taste
level is a little bit different than
that and if I was being totally honest
I'd be like I will be bad for your movie
because I will probably do things to it
that will make it not a less able to go
out that why Marshall movie yeah it's
just the reality of insulting to do is
make a ton really little specific things
exactly how I want to make them for like
Netflix and HBO little TV shows little
movies and then like maybe one out of
twenty one of them will randomly become
popular for some zeitgeist and reason
that I don't understand but if I if I
the only times I've like ever messed
something up that I really wanted to
make it was because I was curating it to
be bigger than it should have been you
know trying to make it yeah well they're
trying to make it something else you
know so I now I'm just let guys [__] it
imma stay I got a little corner of the
sandbox over here you do what you love
dies what you want to do my weird little
things and then maybe I mean I'm so
heartening for me this year seeing like
what moonlight has become you know
that's just like this what they make
that movie 400,000 I mean they could
have you know yeah I made it for about a
million dollars but the key to moonlight
for me it's just like nobody wanted to
make it because there are no stars in it
and it's about the life and story of a
young day blackmail and all of his
feelings yeah it's like oh the lease
commercial movie possible and it's
blowing even if you're a person that
doesn't like my dad would not enjoy
those movies yeah it's the simplicity of
the story it's broken down into three
yeah big moments in this guy's life you
don't really feel like you missed that
much you kind of figure out where he is
at the certain point so a beautiful
story of love the entire time and yeah
yeah I guess for a million dollars
someone goes yeah I can do that now yeah
maybe a little bit racy and the best
part about moonlight is that now when
people want to give me money for movies
and I'm like hey I want to make this
movie they're like
yeah but it's there no real stars in it
and it's I don't know if it's right and
I'm like yeah but moonlight but then all
I have to say yeah so that's what I do
all year long speaking of love getting
back to the end of the notebook because
that to me you know there's levels of
love and I we do for better or worse we
did our vows my wife is one of the
greatest people I know what do you is
that sort of love unimaginable to you
when you first read it yes and no okay
so i have an example of the greatest
love affair of all time in my life which
is Katie's grandparents they were
together for 72 years 72 years yes they
were married avenues end users I heard
that's why Nicholas Sparks wrote the
notebook which his wife's parents or
grandparents were married for like sixty
four years okay so he had the exact same
yes that I had and I got to be around
them and watch them operate one from
when I met Katie when I was 24 years old
you know which is about the most cynical
point in my life I'm an independent
musician I'm living in New York City I'm
in my Brooklyn apartment you know and
I'm watching what they have done and
built they have you know for kids eight
grandkids 16 great gang kids the whole
shebang and she walked by him and he
still pinches her on the ass and that
and I'm like this has to be fake it's
not possible to sustain this and and
then I realized that it wasn't an
either-or it wasn't that a they just got
so lucky to have found each other that
it was perfect and easy or be they're
faking it it was right up the middle and
they did something and it's got a
terrible name but I really believe in
this they they were a fake it till you
make it couple and that's how they
sustained I think that ninety-five
percent of their love was genuine and
real but when the other five percent
when it wasn't working what I would
watch them do is they would just use
that positive momentum to sustain
themselves and even if you didn't really
want to grab her ass in that moment he
would do it and it would boost her
confidence and his love for her so then
she'd be a little bit nicer to him and
then they would just bring them right
back up to speed oh they got it we got
immaculate of that it really literally
would maintain that level through never
letting themselves dip so far they were
fake it in those moments and pull it
back up and it was it's the greatest
lesson
I've ever learned and I'm having
incredibly great relationship with Katie
and we talk about it all the time and I
think the key to our success of keeping
it going is like we don't let it dip too
hard and even if it starts to dip and
we're like I don't really want to be
around you and you don't really want to
be around me it's like well let's just
sit next to each other and listen to
this song we both like let's create the
lowest common denominator of connection
and try and create a piece of bread and
build us a new [__] sandwich that's a
great that's a great way to think about
it because it is i mean look i am on the
road on the weekends and yes getting
back on monday tuesdays and wednesdays
it guy caught we call it reentry yeah
where it's sort of we're living on our
own little islands for the for the two
three or four days I'm gone where we
have to survive on her own yeah and she
has to keep the kids alive and
functioning and I've got to you know
make people laugh at night and depressed
during the day and then it's almost like
you survive on your own and then coming
back together the reentry can be tricky
again sometimes I walk in the door and
it's like hey what's up we miss you so
much and then sometimes it's like I'm on
my way out and it's the midst of the
pinching of the ass thing yeah no matter
what you feel when we still like have to
kiss each other when I when I come home
you know we have to still have that
moment even if it's manufactured dude of
of hey I missed you and I love you and
regardless of how you feel right now not
about me but about everything we just
got to make sure that we I know that you
know that it's important i am i am a i'm
a big believer in it and if I had told
my that to my 16 year old self who had
just read the notebook my 16 year old
self would be like [__] man that
know an ally didn't need to do that no
analia perfect and they were great for
each other you know Anna end but now I
kind of realized I'm like oh I think
that's at least for my knowledge what
I've experienced the most you can hope
for that you've got nine and then
ninety-five percent of it going for you
and then you can just Rev the rest of
the [__] up with a little bit of like
with a little bit of juice look if you
get goodies today hook on the battery I
mean I'm and it just like get it going
but I mean dude you know I will say that
I have a lot of friends right now that
are single whatever reason and I don't
know if it's just like I'm in a
community of artists that like
themselves later and so they don't find
love as early as they used to but I'm
I'm around a lot of late 30s and early
40s single people me to a medium yeah
you're come all the time you're in it
you know and I don't ever want to make
any judgments my thing is like I want to
listen I want to hear what's happening
to you but the bulk of the thing that I
hear like over and over again is an
extreme lack of patience and long game
in most of the dating scenarios I yeah I
hear a lot of punching out of the realm
of who my person could be because of a B
C or D like I had a musician friend of
mine once tell me that he had to break
up with his girlfriend because she said
Andrew Lloyd Webber was a genius and you
like I can't I can never be with
something that's endemic of a massive
personality flaw and I was just like
you're [__] yeah man you're going to
die alone congratulations it's not
Andrew Lloyd Webber it's going to be
something else later and I will go to
the line because by the way I don't mind
who doesn't like that what's with the
mask the guy was great fan on the album
of the opera I've ever seen Matt but I'm
sure I'm sure its fans I didn't cat they
might not be able to Lloyd Webber is me
yeah okay baby looks back on Broadway
under all these years thank God they
brought I mean it was not even that long
gone like that was a serious demand to
bring cats back I mean it was all
Broadway's like 40 years they took it
off for like a year and a half and it
was moving randa together like we would
crack backs like badly well like a
winter garden theater that's I don't
even love it there but that's where
what's a 40 years I think I think what
that is is if you're a 47 year old dad
who's mid-level manager from somewhere
in indiana and you finally got a chance
to bring your family to New York and
show them that you can provide and this
is a cultured experience for my family
cash is the lowest common denominator
that you take them to that everyone be
at work everyone could enjoy cat and and
that that means that show is going to
run forever yeah going back it's a beach
reach it really it's the beach read of
musical yeah we have to have tougher
live I don't know if not tougher for
relationships to keep the love at the
level that we want to be successful with
because you know our schedules are so
crazy I wonder if it's
like Katie's grandparents that I don't
know did they have the kind of jobs
where they saw each other every day and
there was I feel like a continuity and
some sort of regular thing is important
for love I feel like if you are able to
kind of have a pattern down you can you
can get through it and makes things
easier the harder climbs words for us
it's a little different you know I give
you that mostly just because my own
experience has been you know times where
I'm really far apart where I'm a way of
making a movie or times where I'm home
and obviously when i'm home it goes
significantly better in the case of
katie's grandparents when I watch them
they always work together they ran a
nursery together out of their home and
they took care of young children for 30
years then when they were done with that
they were tired and they started and
antiquing business where they would go
buy antiques fix them up travel around
the shows they were always doing things
together always together and so whether
it's a rhythm or whether it's a schedule
I kind of made a decision this year
where I was like all right I'm the
league is wrapped and together this is
not happening anymore so technically I
don't have to be on set and that that
sort of 12 to 13 hour day that we used
to do on the league that's like not
super humane for for family environment
to fat you know and and Katie's doing
the show Legion for three months of the
year in Vancouver and so I'm kind of
like I'm not going to take a set job you
know I'm gonna I'm gonna like write and
produce and I'll act in a couple of
little things here and there but if
they're close to home and and the more i
am home at five o'clock for dinner with
my kids and now now they're like nine
and almost five so it's board game time
now we do cards after game all gonna do
cards cards cards are we going to keep
families together Jack's am i learning
how to play chess I don't how to play
cha this is great so and he's already
more yes it was my fav level oh this is
so great this is like a science project
yeah because I think my his brain is
working at a much higher like
functioning level than mine we always
knew this this is yeah but dude I I have
some friends who
who I asked them she's just one friend
when she's really close with her parents
and and I was like what's what's the key
she's like every night after dinner we
played cards on my parents bed and we
hung on we did that for like a half hour
to an hour and you know her analysis of
it it's like this was a way for me to
have conversations about my life and
what I was doing when I was aged like 12
and 13 when you don't look your parents
in the eye and talk about stuff but if
you're looking at the cards on you're
playing it kind of spills out at you
loosely and you get that time together
you know it's like I did that my dad we
we had a moment where like I realized he
was a Republican and I was a Democrat
when I was like 16 I was like I don't
like this guy anymore really and then we
did not a community would really be a
really close and so what we did is every
day after school we played four out of
seven ping-pong 47 in pool and we wanted
to be together we loved each other we
just couldn't really talk about stuff
yep so we would just be next to each
other listen to music and play games
like the way you and Katie do it now
yeah if you aren't feeling that you just
look at it and then we're gonna do me in
the same room we're going to be a famed
physicals way we love this record we're
going to sit next to each other out and
and you wait we're etching out by trying
to beat each other at ping-pong yeah you
know what the hell yeah at the point is
just being there and yeah and again I
don't know I mean maybe it's that
Catholic [__] and you and me that's just
like where we have parents that are
together and gave us an example of that
for whatever reason but like I I just I
read these blogs and stuff they're about
like the nature of look I'm not making a
grand sweeping statement but there are
these blogs of divorce regret where
people get on Emma just like I wish I
had shut about [__] worse after all
this is done and now I realize like
these were some pretty big endemic
problems but if I had gotten my
expectations to a place and really dug
in maybe I could have made I just
learned Andrew Lloyd Webber yes that
there is yet there and you said hey
we're going to cap's yeah I'm not gonna
[__] talk to you because I hate you
but mr. Mustafa knee we're gonna build
the relation to build something awesome
ism stafa leaves speaking of that though
and this is terrible and I but do you
have you and Katie ever talked about
because Tracy my have about like the end
yeah
I don't know like because I think about
the end of the notebook and just first
of all dementia scares me more than
anything it's in my family I'm I'm sure
I don't know I just physically being
there and having no mental capacity to
understand or remember or sounds like
the literal worst nightmare scenario for
ND on my life so I mean Tracy and I have
talked about like what would be if you
know obviously if it got sick or
whatever but yeah things like that and
like just the way the notebook ends
terrifies me because I wouldn't I feel
like I would be a burden you I think you
won't you feel as though you would be a
burden on the other person and that you
would want to remove yourself from the
equation but you know you don't know how
what what what being around you or being
around me would still make them feel you
know there's a silver lining that you
probably wouldn't know you're a burden
definitely know anything you would never
really know what you just being moms and
pudding and I'm going to be doing fine I
mean we don't really we haven't really
talked about any of that like major
health stuff but the thing that keeps
coming up for us and I guess it's like
midlife he shipped that did just turn 40
is like the people that I know that I'm
close with who are older all tell me the
same thing and they're like it's weird
for you right now being 40 looking back
and saying like oh my god I can't
believe it was 25 years ago that I first
got my driver's license it feels like it
wasn't even that long ago and it looked
me in the eye very sternly and they're
like those 25 years the way those went
by the next 25 are gonna feel like to
[__] and I really believe them and I'm I
am actively trying to figure out ways to
slow down and chew on my life before I
am worm dirt and I don't know how to
stop at all from hurdling towards my
desk well I think by taking some time
off this year and being home that kind
of sad is up that's a way to be like I'm
pumping the brakes on this I'm going to
enjoy some dinners when I can with my
kids well I still want to sit down and
have dinner with me yeah you got it you
got to eat up those meals because I
can't even imagine I believe that's one
hundred percent true that the next 25
years we're going to be collecting
security at sixty three of them right at
71 years ago 71 years old me looks at me
just like I feel just like you like I
think that I'm 40 years old still and it
just flew now I think there is a little
bit of an advantage to our weird like
aberrational lifestyle with the jobs
that we have were like I'm in a
different city and I have these
different experiences some people who do
the same rhythm every day all day long
sometimes those years I think pass a
little more quickly for them because the
memories kind of blend into each other
and they seem similar you know so like
we had our seven years on the lead
together and then it gets a little
different i think those changes can help
mark your time and maybe make things I
don't know that's what marks I'm hoping
I'm hoping that yet that will give me
you know a little bit of that but you
know I'm doing all these things i'm
creating like a little a little media
log where I like write down everything
that I watch and I read now and I see
kind of like how it's affected me what
I've learned and like just like you said
little roadmaps little bookmarks that
I'm like like okay maybe if I don't make
the rest of my life one huge chapter but
a ton of tiny little chapters yeah you
got to make it feel longer yeah somehow
tiny little chapters [__] man I mean I
like the on it really yeah how long do
you want it like you want to live to a
hundred I want to live to be a thousand
five years old I want to be in the
Highlander dude I want to be the only
one I don't want to live forever oh yeah
I guess you don't live forever but I
would like to just slowly just go away
yeah very quickly and quietly and that's
it i just-i can't-- the sickness yeah
the sister we were really scared of the
city I really am scared of the 60 i will
put you down if you have one a little
something a little like well I told
Tracy I said I can't just do it of mice
and men bring me out their backyard hey
Lenny it's gonna be okay yeah and then
that's it I wouldn't mind that I really
wouldn't i think there would be a nice
don't she'd be down for that what if she
gets really mad and you're you and just
does it a little early wait wait wait i
forgot my phone number for a second hold
on yeah yeah that would be terrible it's
really confused see if come in the come
in the backyard when you saw the movie
by the way did you well I can't remember
his name god I so I'm at Iowa is older a
fling go
garner James Garner I mean I want you
know why Garner was so great why why
he's hit whole life he was a tough guy
right now boy yeah we didn't have time
for no Dame's cuz I'm out on the Prairie
and i gotta bring home the bacon and get
them bad guys and he was the saltiest
softie that ever lived once once in a
hole into a book and that's all it all
it took oh so beautiful god I loved it
so much I might have to go watch this
tonight actually I mean yeah that's a
cry I cry on planes no matter what the
movie is but if I if the notebook was on
a plane I would just probably go out the
window and then forget about it yeah if
you if you were to read the notebook now
like if you're like okay now I'm going
to go read the notebook in your and
you're like after this discussion your
prepared do you feel like does that
enrich the notebook experience for you
and all is it like oh you know we've
already talked it out I don't need to
read this thing do you find yourself
having desires to read the books that
you're talking about i have i've started
i'm reading right now either at heart of
darkness oh yeah what's Tarab like yeah
i needed to ask just get it done a
hundred page wick now i'm reading ready
player one which i did that don't know
if you read that right but yes i love
fiction yes and we talked about it but
for me it was more like just getting out
of the computer eight like I want to see
that angle so I'm interesting that but
yeah the notebook would be tough because
the movie I did so I like not but I feel
like if i SAT there and I really wanted
to get emotional i'm going to get it out
and get it out I would you know dive
into it I would say if you haven't seen
Bridges of Madison County that book is a
hell of a read you know I have never
seen a movie I knew it was like strife
in right or am I thinking of it's Meryl
Streep old and on and it's clint
eastwood okay and and the movies not
great the book is great alright so maybe
i'll read the bridge is ahmed's maybe
other bridges and will do will do around
two and we'll talk about anybody out
there wants to do bridges of madison
county with me please let me know and ok
yeah i guess i would read Bridges of
Madison County and feel I think you I
think you would I would cry as you
embark upon your next podcast and your
journey with reading i'll leave you with
one little piece of advice
that was given to me that I just tried
out last week and I'm really happy i did
i met a dad who had a kid in middle
school and he was having trouble
connecting with his kid and so he
decided to read along with his kid all
of his assigned high school reading
books and so they were able to like
share this stuff and Andorra my oldest
was reading a book called wonder that
she really loved she was like you should
read it and so now whenever she's done
with a book she passes it to me oh we
read next to each other at night and
like share and she points out all this
stuff for me so as Jackson starts
cranking into that in the coming years
it's it's the best thing I did i I've
never seen the harry potter movies and
we're doing the whole thing to get it
all now we're reading the books and
going through the best yeah yeah um
speaking of the best you're the best
thanks for doing a buddy I get out again
we miss hanging out i know i miss
pummeling the seat cushion next to yours
with farts I miss sweating on you yeah
I'm sweating on you every cake I would
slash when you got really really upset
because lunch got delayed and you and
throw off your microphone and run out of
the room like a four-year-old beset the
most that was one time I felt really bad
about it but when I'm hungry oh man walk
out of my way and we caught you like
coming back from lunch as we were
heading in and you're just like looking
down and like sorry guys yeah that was
really unprofessional sorry it was one
of my favorites in season six I was
doing Infinite Jest we're all doing
weird [__] by the way if you're
listening and you have not seen blue jay
it is on netflix it is wonderful mark is
unbelievable in it and sarah paulson if
she's something special that lady is she
is she really is now and it was directed
by one of the one alex land who was out
early memory each shooter in the league
camera department so checked out blue
jays on netflix thank you very much
buddy hey buddy and we'll talk to you
guys soon bye
you think
[Music]
nice to talk about your feelings once in
a while to really just let it all off
your chest it's nice right it's fun
doing that with marc de Plaza I thank
him again check out Blue Jay on netflix
you really should it's a wonderful just
sweet beautiful movie and marc has many
other projects that you can watch
animals on HBO is something that he
works on he's an executive producer on
that so I thank him again and guys don't
forget to rate and review the podcast
we're going to come out every single
Tuesday I promise you and I got some
great guests lined up to be doing very
soon and then i had a couple good ones
in the can and i'm going to release so
look forward to it rate review oh I'm
going to be doing stand-up this first of
all thank you to those of you in Denver
who came out this past weekend my god I
love that city it is tremendous every
time I go there I think it can't get any
more fun and it does thank you to Danish
and O'Neill for coming with me Jackie
gold for opening up the show Wendy and
everyone that works over there at the
comedy works I mean hands down and I
don't feel bad saying this truly one of
the best comedy clubs in the world so
thank you to everyone who came out this
past weekend in Denver Charlotte you're
up next this weekend I'm at the comedy
zone thursday friday and saturday come
check it out to shows friday to show
saturday one on thursday i'm going to be
playing golf we'll talk about that next
week so some football people there i'm
looking forward to that yeah I play golf
deal with it okay we're going to talk
about that a little bit not much a
little bit but yes Charlotte come out
next weekend I hope to see you soon
zanies in nashville first weekend in
march so nashville get your [__]
together all right put down the beer and
get over and get to the computer and
start buying tickets alright guys thank
you very much again see Rena ZZ hear me
this book and I'll see you next Tuesday
[Music]
Oh
you all
[Music]
you